Speaker 1: FOX News is now targeting John
Fetterman wife. This is a real study in character
assassination as carried out by the American right
wing and media apparatus. Let's look at the clips
first and then I'm going to explain, Erin. Rupa
assembled what was a roughly 24 hour period of
attacks on Gisele Fetterman. Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: Going after Senate Senator elect John
Fetterman wife Giselle. After she posted this pic,
many were quick to point out that her husband is
partially cropped out and accused Mrs. Fetterman
of using it for her own 15 minutes of fame.
Speaker 1: Okay. So so far it's all fun
and games, right? But let's continue.
Speaker 2: One critic said she wanted this
so badly for herself lol. Another first day
for Senator elect Gisele Fetterman. And
why is she even there? Your thoughts?
Speaker 3: Well, she's a lot better looking than
he is. So as a man who's married to a wife, that
is far better looking. I'm sure John Fetterman
would say I don't even need to be in this photo,
but he's not able to do the job. HARRIS And
and the reality here is that it does feel as
if basically Pennsylvania has elected his wife,
and she certainly is furthering that idea with
these photos. Maybe she's going to step down.
Speaker 1: Oh, so even though it's a joke,
there's still a truth in this. And
now listen to this conspiracy theory
all back up. Back it up a few seconds.
Speaker 3: His wife and she certainly
is furthering that idea with these photos
that maybe she's going to step down and the
new Democrat governor elect is going to end
up appointing her when her husband can't do
the job. What I still in Paris that we could
ever be in a situation where John Fetterman
got elected in Pennsylvania. It's an utter failure
of Pennsylvanians that he's their representative.
Speaker 2: Well, look, every Republican lawmaker
that's dissecting this that you interview will
tell you that they're going to take a close look
at how polling was wrong. They really want to know
what happened, not just in this race, because.
Speaker 1: What happened is as lost, that's what
happened. So Max KENNEALLY explains the mechanism
that is at play here. Fox does it and many do it.
Okay. This is Max writes This segment is a case
study of the four part Fox News method. Number
one, pick a villain, preferably a woman. And or
my. Already. Giselle emigrated from Brazil. Okay,
that's number one. Number two, find something
innocuous. The Fetterman have a long running
gag about John not fitting in picture. So the fact
that in the picture she posted, John Fetterman is
only partially in the picture. It's a known gag.
It's a thing that they've had going for a while.
It's just a joke. Okay. Then Max Kennerley goes
on to explain. Number three is you reframe the
innocuous thing as contemptible. And the fact that
John Fetterman only partially is in the picture,
even though it's a long running joke, is
because Gisella self-centered. It's because
maybe she's really in charge. It's maybe because
Fetterman can't do the job because of his stroke,
etc.. And then part four is you inject that
completely deranged conspiracy theory, which
is John is actually incapacitated and there's a
plot for him to resign. And then Josh SHAPIRO,
who defeated Doug Mastriano to become the
next governor, will appoint Gisele Fetterman
to be the next senator from Pennsylvania. That's
that's the four part system. That's really what's
contemptible. And unfortunately, because you
and I, we understand the parts and we go, okay,
here's how they go from 1 to 2 to 3 to 4. A lot
of the Fox News viewers will just focus on that
last thing. Yeah, you know what? This is a plot.
Fetterman can't do the job because this stroke
and so this is all to make. Gisele Fetterman,
an immigrant from Brazil, woman of color,
a senator, even though she wasn't elected.
There's no evidence for that. Obviously,
this stuff works. Max KENNEALLY
Doing a good job of explaining how.